digamos que a ustedes no les gusta la
compañía abc de que actualmente venden
sus acciones en 50 dólares pero no
tienen el estómago de vender sus
acciones ya que hay una posibilidad de
que pidan una gran cantidad de dinero si
lo hacen pero ustedes aún tienen una
opción literalmente tienen una opción
ustedes pueden comprar una opción de
venta y aquí nos estamos refiriendo a la
versión americana y de la misma manera
que la opción de compra americana en
nuestra opción de venta nos da el
derecho de ejercer la acción en
cualquier momento hasta la fecha de
expiración en la versión europea sólo se
puede ejercer la opción justo el día en
el que vence al igual que la versión de
compra en la que nos daba el derecho de
comprar la acción a cierto precio la
opción de venta hace lo opuesto les da a
ustedes el derecho de vender la acción a
un precio específico
así que la opción de venta que acabo de
inventar aquí la pueden comprar a 5
dólares
y les da el derecho de vender de vender
la empresa abc de a 40 dólares la acción
el tiempo hasta la fecha de expiración y
en un momento vamos a ver cómo se
comporta esto en la opción de que la
compañía se desplome así que vamos a
analizar esta opción en la de la
compañía se comporta como ustedes se
imaginan va a la baja y un mes después
la compañía sigue bajando y ustedes
dicen bueno aplicó mi opción hoy porque
si no va a expirar y ustedes ejercen la
opción aquí y eso lo que les permite a
ustedes es vender la acción a 40 dólares
y si ustedes no la tienen está bien
porque pueden ir a comprar la acción
justo ahora en el mercado que está
barata saben que se está poniendo más
barata la pueden comprar por 20 dólares
y ejercer su opción y venderla por 40
dólares por lo que ustedes estarían
obteniendo 20 dólares ya que se restan
los 20 dólares de la compra de la acción
a los 40 dólares de la venta de esa
acción y le quitamos los cinco dólares
de la compra de la opción y nos queda
una ganancia de 15 dólares aquí lo
escribimos y hacemos un poco de espacio
a la derecha para tener más lugar y esta
es la situación
con la opción de la venta opción de la
venta y si su apuesta va en contra de
ustedes y la acción va aumentando la
situación no va a ser como la opción
corta donde se puede perder una
ilimitada cantidad de dinero en esta
situación vamos a decir que la acción
sigue aumentando aumentando y aumentando
y en cualquier punto por encima de los
40 dólares ustedes pueden decir bueno no
tiene caso que yo dijese mi opción y
dejen que expide y en esa situación
ustedes sólo perdieron el dinero de la
compra de la opción los cinco dólares
aún cuando esa acción llegue a unos 900
mil dólares no se les requiere que la
compren de vuelta como lo harían si
estuviera bajando de precio simplemente
dejan que la opción expire